foreign
hey Dr John thank you for taking my call
I love your show
thank you so much I appreciate you
calling what's up
um
so we have a new situation in our family
um my husband and I have been married
almost 30 years and we have five adult
kids and uh it's a lot of people
yes yes it's great though
um so
Emily
and we're very close
um we're Christian family and
um you know we're kind of always in our
kids ears and you know trying to
guide them and shape them even in their
adult life so how very helicoptery of
you
I'm sure they never go out for chips and
queso to talk about God did mom call you
too that never happened so good okay all
the time it's like you already live here
um so yes you have nailed me perfectly
already so good good all right so what's
up recently none of them have been
married okay I wonder why
yeah after why was anyone ever good
enough for Mama Melissa
well you know I always told my kids when
I was raising them we didn't do the
boyfriend girlfriend thing I always said
to the boys I said you don't need a
girlfriend until you need a wife and to
my girls I said you don't need a
boyfriend until you need a husband
meaning let's not like do this you know
in you know second grade so and so like
so and so like I just I didn't want to
do that I didn't want to put that on
them and I just kind of wanted to shape
them to really think about their future
spouses and as they got older my husband
and I met in youth group we've we've
been joined at the hip since we were 15
and 16. and we're best friends we're
very united front
um and as the kids got older and into
you know teen years and stuff I'd say
you know you guys really need to think
about who what characteristics you want
in your future spouses and you know all
of that see how they act with their
parents see what their parents
relationship is like you know make sure
your spiritual values are similar you
know all this right
well our fourth child who is a boy
joined the Marine Corps when he was uh
just shy of 18 and he just entered his
fifth year of service
and um lucky us were stationed pretty
close he's stationed pretty close to
home
um
he met a girl
um online and fell madly in love
and
um they eloped
very quickly
um in fact it's kind of a situation like
she again
you're hilarious your lack of it it's
not but your lack of approval is so
endearing it's so
well he totally shocked me right of
course right so okay I have to say this
I know this isn't about the call but I
have to just say this out loud is this
is that okay go go
and I hesitate to do this because I
don't want you to hold on to it so can I
just have this opinion and I couldn't
get off the phone you can go that guy's
stupid is that cool
you say what you want to say okay I'm
ready this exact moment is why I think
it's very important for kids to date
because there's not a reference point
physiologically in their bodies
for love for for that ooey gooey feeling
that overwhelm that tsunami of emotion
and if they are old enough to it's kind
of like I want my kid to roller skate
and I want my kid to ride a bike and I
want my kid to ride shotgun in a golf
cart or a four-wheeler before they ever
get in a car
because if I just wait wait wait wait
wait wait 21 here's your car look I can
do whatever I want to go wherever I want
I can drive wherever it's a lot right so
it's so it is not a common for
it's like uh drinking a glass and you
know the ice is at the bottom and said
oh Dimitri Martin joke it's just
fantastic the ice sits at the back back
and then it all just dumps in your face
it's like this right like don't date
don't date don't date I found someone
online she says I love you and it's like
let's get married right now and it's
just this and all of a sudden it's like
no and you've lost it my second favorite
thing is it's when you said
he totally shocked me and I want to tell
you the unbridled
passion
of a child can't be held by their
parents
it can't be held and in fact you don't
actually want that
I think you want to protect your kid
from any sort of hurt ever they're going
to have and by doing so you rob them of
all of their Joy too all of that
wildness all that I did it on my own all
of that crazy
and that becomes about you not about
them but that so every kid you have I
hope they shock you that's what kids are
supposed to do because we're not we we
didn't uh they weren't little puppies
that we trained and not pee in the house
right these are wild men and women that
we are releasing into the world with our
love and with our the lessons we taught
them and our values and they're going to
come up with their own oh you see what
I'm saying it's a it's a terrifying
Enterprise and here we are okay so I
just interrupted you just to I had to
get that out of my system so we're back
no it's good and and I agree and um this
girl is girl number three in his life so
he's only dated two other girls so to
your point I I get it
um we can't change that so here we are
right exactly exactly
he got married okay
okay
um she did not enjoy her home life
um and she's younger she's 18 uh she'll
be 19
um in a couple months so um didn't
didn't really love being at home met
this handsome guy online uh flew to
North Carolina
um I got he brought her over on Sunday
and then I I think they were married by
Tuesday right
in person so very Whirlwind yeah right
so he shows up on Wednesday the next day
with a wedding ring on and I'm like hey
what's that I ordered a Mexican
restaurant eating chips and queso and I
was like dude what's that and he's like
Dad we went to the courthouse yesterday
and we got married
it was like what I I would have paid
money to have been at that table just to
watch that happen I jumped up
oh good for you hey I'm happy for that
that's huge good for you good for you
I I I mean look that's awesome yes
helicopter mom totally but but also
you're great I told her while I was oh
sorry what I told her while I was
hugging her is I said you know since
before he was born
I have prayed for his future spouse
and I'm so glad he found you
was I scared to death I absolutely was
scared to death but that is the truth
and that's my heart and here's the cool
thing awesome I'm glad you didn't lean
into her ear and Whisper while you're
hugging her I'm gonna kill you
that's what Kelly would have done so
good for you good for you no no no no
we've known her for a couple months now
um but she's awesome okay like she's
awesome she is so what's the catch
what's the catch there's a catch here
here's the yeah here's the catch here's
where I need some help
um her
as you can imagine her relationship with
her mom and dad is not great
um she did not tell them that they were
married until just a few weeks ago
um her parents have basically said
um don't come back home until you're
divorced they want nothing to do with my
son they want nothing to do with our
family they have actually since moved to
the state so they're fairly close
um they're not in the same city but
they're fairly close
um and here's here's where I need some
advice
I have
told her that I would
I'm very close with my mom and I have
said family is very important and I want
you to be able to reconcile with your
mom and dad
um
I'm not trying to you know push but
whenever she would come to me to talk
about them I would just say you know I'm
sorry you're going through this I really
hope that one day you guys can reconcile
because I think you want your mom and
dad
in in your life like I think parents
play a key part
um they do but I'd be very careful about
saying that and here's why
there may be
highways of abuse that you don't know
about
and when some when when people tell
somebody who's been in an abusive
situation or an ugly situation often
people who've experienced that
especially 18 and 19 year olds they let
that stuff out centimeter by centimeter
and it starts with yeah I didn't want to
be at home home was really rough I
didn't like it there that is them slowly
testing the waters
is this okay to talk is this a safe
place
and when people are like man you really
need to go back to your family you're
going to miss them they start to feel
insane
right and so I think your heart is
beautiful you had a great relationship
with your mom and that was super
important to you sometimes the greatest
relationship with between a mom and a
daughter is a severed one
because Mom was brutal to me
and it doesn't surprise me that she
comes to you somebody who is super smart
super fun who loves her husband as much
as she does if not way more
and who is I mean you you are you sound
so grounded and rooted in who you are
right and so
um
for her somebody who might have come
from a troubled home and again I'm
projecting into her world her parents
might have just wanted to have a curfew
at 18 and she's like I'm getting married
and so who knows right but if I may yeah
if I can inject here she has said
um she feels that
um she has an older brother who's in
therapy that has this is just word of
mouth but brother has said that
um the therapist has told them that the
parents are emotionally abusive and
narcissistic okay and so when I had told
her boy I hope that one day you can
reconcile with healthy boundaries sure
you know that's right that's right but
but that that reconciliation at this
point will never be hers to own
because her mom and dad who walked away
from her
she didn't run away from them she got
married as an adult a very very young
adult yeah they looked at her and said
we are breaking up with you
and so I think that I hope y'all can
reconcile with boundaries someday is
I hope your mom sees what an amazing
young woman you are
oh that's good okay one day okay the
woman I'm seeing standing before me
right now who makes my son light up like
a Christmas tree I hope one day your mom
sees how amazing you are because I see
it
that's different than okay I hope y'all
can reconcile someday because every kid
goes through a season and at last well
into adulthood for folks especially in
abusive situations
of asking of their you've heard this it
sounds so woo and cheesy but it's not
that little nine-year-old kid inside of
you going what was so bad about me
are you so mean to me or why did you
care more about your phone or care more
about your job what was so wild in your
life that
you hit me all the time like whatever
the thing is right and so
um
I don't ever want her to own that her
parents looked at her and they said
because of your choice we abandon you
until you make different choice and that
could be marriage that could be
um that could be job that could be
because she's doing drugs that could be
any number of reasons but Mom and Dad
are the ones that walked out
and they gave her a boundary and the
boundary is you will divorce that
military guy
and she's not gonna do that
they have done what I think is an
unforgivable sin for parents and that is
force their child to choose them or
their spouse
that's a that's a brutal decision and
what you did like I hope all the parents
listening what you did in that
restaurant
the number of times I've met with a
parent who has said especially I was
working in the universities
whatever conversation my kid came home
and said ex my kid came home and said
well my kid came home and said they've
been struggling with this they've
they said I would do anything to have
that moment back because I didn't handle
it right
and you did Melissa that's amazing the
fact that you got up in your first move
was a hug even though inside your your
heart had melted and was leaking out
your feet that that's amazing and by the
way when your kids get older
you can tell him that because you get a
moment too here's what here's like so
all all
Kumbaya side here's the big picture you
had a very clear picture of what your uh
like later adult years were going to
look like
and it was going to be your sons would
marry beautiful girls who would look
like X or Y and your daughters would
marry beautiful boys who look like X and
Y and all of y'all's family would
vacation together and y'all would hang
out and that wasn't your picture to
paint
and so there's going to be a true grief
that you have because you have been a
parent who's tried to control every
variable since they were zero
and now you turn these amazing men onto
the world one of whom is already
dedicated a half a half a decade to
service
of other people
and he's a wildcat man he's out there
and so you're gonna have to grieve that
picture because his her parents don't
want anything to do with you and you
can't fix sex you didn't do anything
wrong
okay and that's the picture I think that
I'm grieving like I love her for him and
I love their story and I think the
longer their marriage lasts the cooler
their story is going to become
absolutely right it's like a Nicholas
Sparks romance novel developing and or
one of Kelly's murder podcasts it could
go either way it could go either way I'm
just kidding I'm talking
but you're right this could be a
beautiful story but it's there it's not
yours yeah but you're right because my
husband and I met at a Baptist Church
and his parents are friends with my
parents and
we don't vacation together but we could
and so
the second part of my question was not
just how like should I stop suggesting
that she reconciled like what what
should be my words to her which thank
you that's perfect I love that but the
second part was I haven't made contact
or tried to make contact with her mom
and dad I actually did meet her dad he
showed up at our house
um
um to check on her which
I don't know I kind of I gave him props
for that how was that meeting
um you know it
it was okay a little awkward
um my husband is law enforcement so you
know we have a police cruiser in the car
and he showed up and knocked on the door
and he said he was very nervous but this
was shortly after she had come down here
um and they just wanted to lay eyes on
her because she had really put just a
hard stop she she wasn't responding
to text or calls or anything and one day
if my daughter Josephine listens to this
if she ran off and got on a plane and
married somebody at 18
I can guarantee you I would be on that
front porch the following day
of course right right so good for that
guy yeah good for him and and I and I
told her I said you know I give him
props for coming I'm sure that you know
but he just wants to make sure you're
okay and I get that and
um so you know it was we weren't hugging
when he showed up but I mean we were all
very cordial he he did shake hands with
my son at this point he didn't know that
they were married and she didn't want to
tell him so it was just some layers of
awkwardness but um I would run it
through her I would run through her and
say I am feeling this this this sense
inside of my mom heart that I want to
reach out to your parents
let them know that you're safe and
you're doing amazing and if they ever
want to connect we'd love to connect
with them
um and she might tell you please please
do not do that
and if at least in this season I would
honor that
okay um all right so or she might say
you can do whatever you want but I I
would again what you're giving her is
something she may have never had which
is a an older adult who trusts her
and that you like you are you are in a
weird way practicing your new
relationship with her
and that is you going first saying I
don't trust you here's what I think is
the right thing to do I think married
parents like at least need to wave and
say hi to each other and shake hands
um so I'm feeling this Mom since to do
that I wanted to sit down with you I
also think it would be a beautiful thing
as much as possible this is pie in the
sky but if you all live in the same
Community it'll be awesome if just you
and her once a month set up a breakfast
together
kid she's a kid right
um so I guess I didn't tell you right
now they are living at my home until he
gets space housing set up yeah so I have
lots of access and um it's but don't
have too much access oh actually you
know what yeah as much as you want
because they're in your house that's
what they get for getting married and
then moving into their mom's house and
it's temporary they don't plan on being
here long base housing takes a while to
get sure
um get set up but um things are going
well but like they have their own space
and so you know we might
come together you know I I get to see
her every day you know she's found a job
already I mean she's really doing
amazing so I I but thank you but you're
gonna you are gonna be moved by the
run-ins what I call accidental Community
you're going to be moved by the hallway
interactions in the early morning at the
coffee pot interactions
with that little girl's desperate for
she's not a little girl she's 18 but
she's a little girl with that young
woman is desperate for
is another adult to sit across a
breakfast room table and say tell me
tell me about it
yeah a focused and because what you're
giving her right now is Twitter bites
and what she needs is a store she needs
a book
and I don't think she's ever had that
yeah that that
of me and um she's so desperate for for
Love from her mom
yeah that isn't there it was it was it
was so funny
um shortly after they got married Maybe
three four weeks after they had gotten
married and and we're here my husband
and I had um it wasn't really an
argument but you know we had like the
house was kind of a mess we had just
gotten back from a trip and there was
stuff everywhere and I was like look
dude there this his his father had given
him a bunch of like football stuff like
we're big Michigan football fans I was
like there's stuff in like eight oh go
Blue there's something like eight rooms
of the house I work from home I was like
look dude I have got to have help like
we need to get this stuff I I need to
put somewhere and and he was like I
don't know why you're getting upset with
me and I was like dude I'm not upset I'm
just saying I need help we need to you
know contain this and put it somewhere
because I got to get back to work
tomorrow and there's normal stuff you
know the dogs and I was like this is
just crazy and my older daughter was
here and and my husband has said I just
don't know why you're yelling at me and
I said Katie am I yelling I don't feel
like I'm yelling and Katie says well Mom
you know how when you ask Dad why is he
yelling and we know that dad's kind of
annoyed and he's not really yelling but
we get where you're coming from she's
like yeah you're doing that and I was
like oh okay all right family I'm sorry
I'm not trying to raise my voice I'm not
trying to yell I just need everyone to
help me get the stuff put up paint uh my
daughter-in-law like looked up and she
said wait someone's yelling who's
fighting like what what's going on
because she said at home yes things are
flying through the air and profanity is
flying and divorce is being threatened
and
um you know just all sorts of so let me
say this my wife said this the other day
and it was instructive and I'll leave
you with this
um
she had a really stressful couple of
days doing some stuff and she's in the
middle of a huge she's finishing up her
book and she's she's editing it's just a
wild season for her
and I was sitting on the couch which is
something I hardly ever do I just plug
down the couch and she said hey
I'm gonna turn a show on because I need
to borrow some of your nervous system
for a while
because I was super chill
and I laughed and said you got it and
she leaned way I mean burrowed in like a
puppy does and
after the show was over like 45 minutes
or how long the show was she's like ah
thanks
and I want you to keep that in your mind
that this little girl this this like you
call a little girl she's a 18 19 20 year
old woman
um this woman needs to borrow your
nervous system for a while
she needs a new picture speaking of new
pictures of what a functioning house
looks like
of what a disagreement between two
people who are committed to the end of
time to each other looks like clean up
your football stuff what football stuff
why are you yelling I'm not yelling and
you both love each other
and it's a matter of what pile goes
where not a matter of can I sleep in
this house tonight
and so she's going to be borrowing your
nervous system you're going to be
painting a picture for her of what
marriage could look like because she
does not have a good picture of what
marriage can look like
and it will be a hundred percent to be
expected that the first fight she gets
in with your son that she flies off the
handle because that's what she knows
that's what her body knows
and you're given another picture another
picture and if you set up a once a month
or once every two weeks breakfast
together not at home but in a different
air in a different geographic location
you'll sit down and you talk
and you listen way more than you talk
and just hear her story
and look her in the eye and let her know
that she's loved and okay man you're
talking about that is generational
change now
but for the time being I would run it
through and and by the way it's okay to
tell them this hey guys I had a picture
of what your courtship and marriage
would look like this wasn't it so we get
it we get a minute and I've told
countless 18 to 25 year olds hey you
just blew up your whole parent's world
with who you married or who you're in
love with that's great but they get a
minute too
and so I think it's fair to say we did
not have on our radar a weekend romantic
marriage
to someone you met on the internet that
was in our picture and it wasn't our
picture to draw but we drew one anyway
so we get a minute we're figuring this
out too you get to say that also
but for the time being I would run that
through her daughter and I would I would
tell say the words I trust you
right now my mom Instinct says I'm gonna
reach out to your parents and try to
make a put an olive branch on the table
and connect with them but I trust you
you think that's a good idea or not a
good idea
and let's go from there let's go from
there
um
man they're really lucky to have you you
sound like a pretty awesome pretty
awesome Mom who loves her kids
stuff I'm a little too much but you love
your kids and that's amazing
it's awesome awesome that you called
thank you so much
foreign